blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman the Joe Biden White House
is now facing what is absolutely the
biggest foreign policy crisis of the
still relatively new presidency and
administration of the Biden White House
there has been an absolutely terrible
terrorist attack in Kabul Afghanistan
this is part of the broader context of
Joe Biden deciding to make good
essentially on the plan that Donald
Trump claimed to have now of course
Donald Trump ultimately did not leave
Afghanistan essentially ran out of time
but as far as we knew planned to leave
just like Joe Biden ultimately decided
to do and and this is one of those areas
where if you are looking for the sort of
simplistic black or white mannequin
analysis of what is going on in
Afghanistan there's plenty of places to
get that there's no question about it
and we've seen many of those simplistic
analysis analyzes come from The Usual
Suspects the paid political Consultants
on both right and left for different
reasons
we've seen them come from the military
industrial complex friendly generally
pro-war corporate media and by Pro War I
don't mean they want war per se but they
want conflict and salaciousness and they
know that military conflicts generate
ratings and unfortunately all of those
analyzes fall short and there's good and
there's bad and there's right and
there's wrong and it actually requires a
little bit more thinking in order to get
something approximating
um a view that considers a totality of
what is going on so we'll work backwards
Thursday
two explosions happened in an area right
by the Kabul Airport this is an airport
that has become a central location in
what is now taking place in Afghanistan
which is many people trying to leave
there are Americans trying to leave
there are uh locals trying to leave and
seek Asylum or Refugee status in the
United States and elsewhere as you are
seeing the Taliban increasingly prevent
people from leaving to some degree and
also now we have introduced Isis Isis
claiming responsibility for the two
explosions these were suicide bombings
as of this morning the latest numbers
were 182 people killed including 169
Afghan civilians and 13 members of the
United States military these are the
first military casualties in Afghanistan
since February of 2020 Joe Biden was
meeting the remains of the 13 deceased
American Military members
when they arrived in the United States
over the weekend so let's go through
each item here because you know it's
actually kind of a bummer
I know that we're going to get really
simple black or white analysis from most
in the media the right is saying this is
all terrible because Biden's incompetent
and Trump would have done it great well
no he wouldn't know he would not have
some on the left are saying this was
carried out the wrong way Biden was
wrong to leave or just this is perfect
and there everything has been gone
swimmingly all of these takes fall short
Joe Biden was 100 correct to leave
Afghanistan doesn't change anything
about that Joe Biden was completely
right to leave Afghanistan this does not
mean as a result of this terrorist
attack that we go back in
my preference right of course we we
might I don't believe it means we go
back in but it does mean that Joe Biden
has a crisis to deal with here now for
those saying this crisis is what's
tanking Joe Biden's approval and this
crisis is going to prevent Democrats
from winning in 2022 I disagree and I
disagree on both and we're going to go
into that more tomorrow the political
implications of this part of it is
voters have a very short-term memory
part of it is foreign policy actually
matters surprisingly little when it
comes to how people vote in elections in
the United States we'll get back to that
but the fact that after just a few days
of the United States pulling back you
have the Taliban taking over and then
you have Isis versus the Taliban this
actually reinforces how completely
untenable our involvement was in
Afghanistan we have to stay forever in
order to prevent this that's proof that
we shouldn't be involved since the only
way to keep keep things even relatively
calm apparently is to stay involved
indefinitely it's not viable it's not
viable unless you believe in the United
States as the never-ending policeman of
the world which I don't that's not my
foreign policy view I thought it wasn't
the view of a lot of trumpists when it
was Trump saying we're going to get out
of there now all of a sudden those same
people have changed their mind I have
not changed my mind on this uh Trump
should have left Biden did leave Obama
should have left but he didn't okay now
of course the right is going after Joe
Biden well yeah Joe Biden's a Democrat
they're going to go after Joe Biden yes
this is a crisis but it would have been
the same crisis under Donald Trump we're
seeing all the normal experts on foreign
policy come forward
and say oh we should have stayed this is
a humiliation for Biden
um should have gotten out differently I
have a completely different perspective
without denying that this has not gone
well because it hasn't gone well we
rarely see presidents act this
decisively in getting us out of a
commitment around the world when
presidents act decisively it's usually
to start an incursion and it's
considered patriotic by the right when
George W bush said on my order we have
started uh attacks in Iraq after 9 11
and all of this WOW decisive and
Powerful well hold on a second is it
decisive and Powerful to start an
incursion without actually thinking
through the consequences the way George
W bush did this is the opposite but it
is decisive Joe Biden has drawn a line
and is getting us out of what George W
Bush started what Barack Obama didn't
end what Donald Trump didn't end Biden
is ending it in the first year of his
presidency and that's good
and the situation has become very
chaotic and now Joe Biden has to figure
out what to do but remember that the
status quo before we left was not some
uh Utopia for the Afghan population 200
000 Afghans killed since we went in it's
been chaotic for years in Afghanistan
but nobody was paying attention and now
suddenly people are saying it only just
got chaotic because Joe Biden decided to
leave that's wrong it got more chaotic
without a doubt and now we have pundits
and so-called experts saying the least
interesting things just stay stay for a
month stay for a year stay for another
20 years how is that even considered
remotely serious unless your view of
American foreign policy is Uber
interventionist that's not my foreign
policy Joe Biden did a good thing by
leaving
left right and corporate media in their
own ways are slamming him but the
decision was the right one uh now you
have to figure out what to do with the
chaos all the same people who ignored
this for decades are now jumping in like
they've been paying attention and saying
we should be staying or we should have
left this way or we should have like
give me a break guys this is the same
media that mostly rode willingly into
George W Bush's Iraq war who are now
saying oh let's stay in Afghanistan give
me a break there are real problems I
don't understate for a second the dire
situation that is happening in
Afghanistan life lost tragedy but we've
had that for 20 years and barely a peep
from a lot of these same people now it's
a cynical uninformed attempt to just go
after Joe Biden Joe Biden deserves
criticism in all of this but leaving was
the right decision Trump should have
left Obama should have left resist the
urge to demand that something be either
perfect
or terrible okay reality is more
complicated and it's too complicated for
the really predictable boring hot takes
that we are seeing including from all
sorts of corporate media with various
different political Stripes we're going
to keep talking about it this week by
the way one last thing I got a few
emails from people saying David why
haven't you talked about Afghanistan the
first week of this crisis I was gone I
just I just wasn't here my guest hosts
talked about it since getting back I've
done nine segments on Afghanistan this
today is number 10. give me a break guys
find something else to complain about
okay let's talk about what is uh
increasingly likely going to be the
addition of the covid-19 vaccine to
school requirements uh School
vaccination requirements if kids want to
go to public schools now why am I
wording it this way
because most States every state already
has a list of vaccines that are required
for students to attend public school and
we're going to talk about this in some
detail the news that is getting people
all worked up is a report that Dr
Anthony fauci backs a covid-19 mandate
for U.S school children Reuters
reporting on this choosing a terrible
picture of Anthony fauci looking like
he's doing a Nazi salute why this
picture was chosen I don't know but the
report from Reuters is Dr fauci top U.S
infectious disease expert said Sunday he
supports covet vaccine mandates for
children attending schools as the highly
contagious Delta variant of the
coronavirus continues to fuel a surge in
cases in the nation let's take a look at
Dr fauci himself saying it yesterday on
CNN remembering of course that children
under 12 aren't even eligible yet this
is Dr Dr fauci saying what he would
support but the vaccine isn't even
approved for kids Under 12 yet let's
take a look I believe that mandating
vaccines for children to appear in
school is a good idea and remember Jake
this is not something new we have
mandates in many places and schools
particularly public schools that if in
fact you want a child to come in we've
done this for decades and decades
requiring polio measles mumps rubella
hepatitis so this would not be something
new requiring vaccinations for children
to come to school so this makes sense
and it's really not even remotely
controversial we're just adding a
vaccine we would be if this happened we
would just be adding another vaccine to
the list of vaccines that are required
for public school kids this is a vaccine
that the Pfizer vaccine is now approved
by the FDA and part of what the right
does is create fear and outrage and
uncertainty and doubt over
non-controversial things and this is
good these are going to be the next
battle lines if you look at the State of
Texas a bill was introduced in the Texas
legislature to add the coveted vaccine
to the required uh School vaccine list
there was another bill introduced in
Texas that goes directly counter which
would ban adding the covet vaccine as a
required vaccine for schools so we're
going to see where that goes in Texas
Texas of course has a right-wing
legislature and it will probably be the
latter rather than the former but it is
important to remember that a whole bunch
of States already have these rules let's
start with the liberal state of New York
when you look at New York you see very
clearly you need the dtp vaccine that's
diphtheria tetanus and pertussis if
you're going going to pre-k you need
four doses for kindergarten through age
through grade five
you need five or four doses or three
depending on the age of the kids for
grades six to twelve you need three
doses of the dtp
um polio vaccine three doses or four
based on the age MMR kids in pre-k need
a dose of MMR everybody beyond that
needs two doses Hep B is on the list uh
varicella Chickenpox vaccine now
required once you get to grade seven you
need the meningococcal vaccine okay the
point here is New York already has a
list of all of these vaccines they're
they're just there's no new structure
it's just add the cobit vaccine to that
now if you say well sir New York very
liberal State let's look Instead at the
state of Alabama
Alabama if you look also has this
requirement and it's kind of strict look
at this the state of Alabama does not
recognize philosophical moral or ethical
exemption from vaccination a medical
exemption may be issued by a physician
or an Alabama religious exemption may be
obtained some states have even done away
with religious exemptions but Alabama is
already pretty tight on this and then
look at the list attendees of daycare
and Head Start must be vaccinated
against diphtheria tetanus pertussis
measles mumps rubella influenza type B
polio and chickenpox we're just talking
about adding one more vaccine and I
could go on and give you more
requirements for older kids so when we
talk about this issue it's really
important not to let them frame the
battle lines as we're going from nothing
to mandating a vaccine no we're going in
theory from mandating six or seven
vaccines to adding a seventh or eighth
that's just been approved by the FDA
don't let them set the terms of the
debate
um and we will ultimately see where this
goes but remember it's not even approved
for kids under 12 yet there is uh the
next step would be 5 to 11 and that's
being evaluated right now this is going
to be a fight but it's going to be a
necessary one sadly because of the level
of ignorance that we have in the United
States let me know what you think will
ultimately happen with these School
vaccine mandates find me on Twitter at
dpacman we are getting dangerously close
to 1 billion YouTube views when we get
there we're at 998 million when we get
to a billion YouTube views we'll be
sending out an email blast with a great
membership special get on our newsletter
to be notified at davidpackman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich Yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes I
recently read A Brief History of Time Of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction category stories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the David packman show is
funded by viewers Like You by podcast
listeners like you the podcast by the
way I don't know what's going on with
the audio podcast but we are back to
sort of like election 2020 levels with
the daily audio podcast downloads I
don't know what's causing it but we love
it regardless wherever you listen
wherever you watch you can grab a
membership at joinpakman.com and get
instant access to the extra Daily Show
it's an additional show every day for
our members sign up at joinpakman.com
you've got a coupon code better21 that
you can use anytime and save bigly off
of that membership hey um I want to call
your attention to something maybe you
forgot about does everybody remember
when a few months ago the corporate
media decided that now we have to talk
about the lab leak theory of covid and
we all have to say hey could it have
been made in a Chinese laboratory as a
bio weapon could it accidentally have
leaked from the lab and of course some
of us like me had all along been saying
the exact same thing
investigate everything why would we
without investigating say something is
true or isn't true let let's investigate
the origins of kovid but until we have
evidence that it came from a lab or was
deliberately made and released as a bio
weapon until we have evidence for that
it would be irresponsible to suggest
that that is likely and that's what I
said in 2020 and that's what I said in
early 2021 and it's what I said a few
months ago when the story was raging but
for some reason a few months ago the
story was everywhere in the media and it
was framed as why are some like Dr fauci
and the left whoever why are people
covering up and preventing an
investigation into the lab League Theory
now the reality was just about everybody
was saying sure investigate it
look into it but we just don't have
evidence right now that that's actually
what took place but the cover-up
hypothesis is prototypical of how you
generate more media interest you not
only float an idea but you claim that
the idea is being suppressed that the
idea is being covered up and this
actually worked because a couple months
ago members of the media actually
started asking Joe Biden and Biden
Administration officials about it they
would ask Jen saki in the Press briefing
room Jen does the Biden Administration
oppose investigating what the origin no
no it doesn't oppose we're fine with an
investigation uh I think it was Peter
Steve Ducey Peter Ducey who asked Joe
Biden about it and Joe Biden said
investigate go ahead and investigate it
and just about everybody was saying we
don't rule out anything let's find out
but we don't yet have evidence that
that's the case now here's the really
important part in understanding these
media Cycles
when this bubbled up a couple of months
ago and Joe Biden was asked about it and
so was jensaki there was no new evidence
at that time that would make us say this
now looks much more likely so let's ask
about it it came in and then it suddenly
went away and it became a non-story it
may come back again at no point was
there really any reason to think that
kovid was a bio weapon that came from a
lab it's just the perfect prototypical
example of how something becomes a story
in the media and then just as quickly
the story goes away and we don't even
really understand why and this was the
case all along and then very quietly a
few days ago we got a new report
published written about in nature which
explains that quote the intelligence
investigation is inconclusive on viruses
Origins but finds it wasn't weaponized
and it is unlikely to have been
engineered
according to the Declassified key
takeaways issued by the office of the
Director of National Intelligence and
the intelligence Community more broadly
it's been assessed that the covet virus
likely first appeared in Wuhan no later
than November of 2019 emerged without
the knowledge of Chinese authorities and
was not developed as a bioweapon most
agencies also agreed though with low
confidence that it was probably not
genetically engineered although two and
agencies believe we don't yet have
enough evidence to say for sure so under
when you read it if you read it with the
conspiratorial mind you say this is part
of the cover-up they're sort of not
closing the door completely to the
possibility but but if you actually look
at it for what it is understand that for
a very long time there was fear
uncertainty and doubt generated around
the idea that the true Origins were
being covered up the truth is we never
had evidence to believe Eve that this
was bioengineered or leaked from a lab
or released as a bio weapon we didn't
have evidence for that we couldn't rule
it out sometimes in science you can't
rule things out but you don't have
evidence for them that allowed for
people to weaponize the hypothesis to
attack others to claim that there were
bad liberal people lying and covering
this up and I am still open to the
possibility that this was being studied
and it leaked or whatever I don't think
we should put any kind of limitation on
studying it but we don't have evidence
for it and it's very similar to the use
of the migrant Caravan stories or
stories of Middle Eastern terrorists
coming through the U.S Mexico border all
these things are physically possible
they're theoretically possible someone
could go from the Middle East to
Guatemala and then come to Mexico and
physically cross the U.S Mexico border
we don't actually have evidence that
that's going on and there there's this
churn of unverifiable rage-inducing
propaganda there are legitimate
questions about the exact chemistry of
the Wuhan strains and about events at
the Wuhan lab it's been discussed in
reputable media let's investigate it
there is no no reason right now
to think that it came from a lab just
like before so how much are we going to
sort of repeat the same story absent
that evidence now one other thing
there's another important thing
when people say
this is being discussed everywhere
online like how is this not a serious
story the discussion online is biased
towards controversy and conspiracy you
just have to understand that and that's
uh important when we talk about the
Baseline of a lot of these discussions
but the perfect example the story came
two months ago and then it went and we
still don't have more evidence that any
of those hypotheses are true I'm going
to play a couple of clips for you here
of a statement and an interview that
Donald Trump produced and gave a few
days ago in relation to what's going on
in Afghanistan and I have to tell you if
a Democratic president had downplayed
911 and Osama Bin Laden the way that
Donald Trump does in this interview
they would be getting covered on Fox
News as unpatriotic uh Traders 24 hours
a day probably for a week or longer okay
let's take a listen to this first clip
this is Donald Trump on the Sean Hannity
program look at Al baghdadi he was the
founder of Isis we took him out nobody
could find him for 15 years far bigger
than Osama Bin Laden far bigger Osama
Bin Laden bad and he hit you know the
World Trade Center and it was a horrible
thing but al-baghdadi was the founder of
Isis so there is Donald Trump
downplaying 911 saying the what's the
core of this Obama got Osama
and Trump wants to say I did better I
did more as well as justify the idea
unfounded that had he overseen the
withdrawal from Afghanistan rather than
Joe Biden it would have gone much better
we have no evidence to suggest that
everything Trump did uh turn to crap so
there's no reason to suggest to believe
that Donald Trump would have handled the
uh Retreat from Afghanistan any better
than did Joe Biden but Trump is
downplaying the importance of Osama bin
Laden's capture and kill uh being killed
and downplaying by virtue of doing that
9 11. if a Democratic president did this
they would be they would be calling uh
for the head of such a Democrat Donald
Trump also during this interview talking
about Isis X which sounds like a band
more than a terrorist group take a
listen to this and Isis sex as you know
I knocked out a hundred percent of the
Isis caliphate I knocked it out in Syria
Iraq we knocked it out so it doesn't
have a new ice is called Isis X yeah so
I actually I'm trying to think back I
might have gone to high school in fact
with the um with with the bassist for
Isis X anyway
um here is Donald Trump then in talking
about ending the war in Afghanistan he
actually says he did want to keep troops
there take a listen to this but we had
to get out with dignity we had to take
our 80 billion dollars worth of
equipment we had to do all of the things
that you know we had to do and then I
would have blown up all the air bases
but I would have kept Bagram because
bagram's located right next to China
right near China and Iran and it's in
Afghanistan so we had the whole group
covered they spent 10 billion dollars
building it and we handed out the keys
so understand how amazing that is
for all the talk about Trump was going
to get us out which he failed to do for
all of that talk and then now the
criticism which I think is a fair
criticism I don't want Biden sending
people back in but for all the
criticisms criticism of saying Joe got
us out and cause chaos but then he's
also not really getting us out because
he's sending people back in Trump is
admitting there I would have kept people
there to keep Bagram we would have done
it so even Trump's full removal of
troops from Afghanistan he admits there
would not even actually have been a full
removal and the most important Point
here is there's no empirical reason to
think that Donald Trump would have done
a good job there's no historical reason
last thing Trump put out a statement
about Afghanistan one of these direct to
camera things and it was published on
Fox News Sean Hannity program why maybe
because Trump has lost access to all of
his other platforms for spreading
disinformation I don't know uh but let's
take a listen to a little bit of that
as one nation America Mourns the loss of
our brave and Brilliant American Service
members in a Savage and barbaric
terrorist attack in Afghanistan these
Noble American warriors laid down their
lives in the line of duty they
sacrificed themselves for the country
that they loved racing against time to
rescue their fellow citizens from Harm's
Way
they died as American heroes and our
nation will honor their memory forever I
want to express my deepest condolences
to the families of those we have lost
today all Americans grieve alongside you
together we also pray that God will heal
the other courageous American Service
members who were wounded in this heinous
attack
in addition our hearts are with the
families of all the innocent civilians
who died
and with the many men women and children
who were terribly injured in this act of
evil
this tragedy should never have taken
place it should never have happened and
it would not have happened if I were
your president and of course it almost
certainly would have happened if Donald
Trump were president so the important
points here are as I mentioned at the
top of the show this is the perfect
story for Monday morning quarterbacking
getting out of Afghanistan was the right
decision by Joe Biden it was a decisive
decision and predictably it led to chaos
go back to my Clips uh about when Donald
Trump was looking at doing this it
predictably led to chaos and tragedy and
death and that has to be dealt with and
Joe Biden has a crisis on his hands but
this idea that Trump would have done it
right is an absolutely pathetic bogus
idea for which we have no evidence at
all just there's simply no reason to
think Trump would have handled this well
because he handled nothing well we'll
have more on this on the David Pacman
Show Instagram find us there at
davidpack show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right um over the weekend I was just
getting email after email after email
from people in the audience saying David
look here's another one of these
prominent anti-vaxxers who just died of
covid here's another one of these
prominent anti-masters who just died of
covet here's another one of these uh
Ivermectin people who just died of covid
I had three stories actually planned for
today we're only going to get to two of
them and I think these are important to
go over for a few different reasons
which we're going to get to uh the third
one we're actually going to get to
tomorrow because it's a little different
it's a militia member who was also
anti-mask and anti-vaxx who died of
covid but let's just jump right into the
first one we now have the third
conservative radio host who condemned
the covet vaccine who has died of covet
if you didn't understand what was going
on and you just zoomed out you might say
wow being a right-wing radio host seems
really dangerous in the United States in
some way this is Mark hernia he was a
Mainstay on Talk Radio in Daytona this
is the state of Florida a conservative
Florida radio host who spoke out against
covet vaccines died after a weeks-long
fight with the virus marking the third
radio personality to die from
coronavirus who publicly rejected
vaccines the death of Mark Bernier 65
who was a Mainstay on Talk Radio in
Daytona was announced Saturday night by
the radio station wndb that he was
affiliated with for three decades it is
with great sadness that wndb and the
southern Stone Communications announced
the passing of Mark Bernier who informed
and entertained listeners on wndb for
over 30 years we kindly asked that
privacy is given to Mark's family during
this time of this time of grief
I think that there it would be more
useful if they didn't hide the cause of
death in these announcements this is an
it's almost exactly like the Phil
Valentine thing where the radio station
statement doesn't mention the anti-vax
element and the covet death even if it's
not you don't have to attack the person
but just say of covet folks let's send
this together get the vaccine wear a
mask where recommended there would
actually be some more that comes from
this that would be useful
um Bernier was known for inviting
different viewpoints on the show
including Democrats but had publicly
railed against vaccines the Daytona
Beach News Journal reported Bernier had
been hospitalized since August 7. when
Florida's Democratic agriculture
commissioner Nikki fried in July urged
people to get vaccines on Twitter by
saying the greatest Generation had to
defeat the Nazis to preserve our way of
life you're only asked being asked to
get a shot so be a patriot Bernier
replied on the platform should say now
the U.S government is acting like Nazis
get the shot
died of covid
likened the vaccine
to vac to Nazism
dead of covet okay
freed is challenging Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis in 22 said my heart goes
out to his family and friends we covered
this story previously on August 4th
another Florida conservative radio hosts
who had criticized the coronavirus
vaccine dick Farrell also died from
coveted complications uh Farrell had
worked at several radio stations and was
a fill-in anchor on Newsmax he strongly
condemned the vaccine posting on July
3rd why take a vaccine promoted by
people who lied to you all along about
masks where the virus came from and the
death toll of course there were no lies
about masks in March of 2020 Dr fauci
said it's probably not necessary for the
general population by April of 2020
fauci and everyone else was saying we
now know more wear the mask
um lied about where the virus came from
that's just lab leak hypothesis stuff
that's unproven and lied about the death
toll it's actually been the State of
Florida that has been
um uh playing fast and loose with the
statistics and actually that I I
mentioned this before but let me just
slightly digress over the weekend I got
a bunch of emails from people saying
David why do Florida's death numbers
look so good
anytime you look at Florida's death
count it's low it's it's just collapsed
this is a game Florida is playing and I
told you about it a week and a half ago
what Florida is doing is they are
reporting covet deaths a full week at a
time for the previous week the way most
of these websites work is if Florida
doesn't report cases for yesterday it
shows up as a zero if Florida doesn't
show uh report cases deaths for the day
before it shows as zero so what Florida
is constantly doing is saying okay it's
now August 30th
here's the death numbers for August 22nd
23rd 24th and 25th and those go crazy
but then because they've not reported
the recent dates it crashes to almost
zero and then next week they'll report
the numbers for this week the point is
Florida is playing a game whereby
delaying reporting by a week and doing a
week at a time it always looks like the
last five to seven days are just looking
really good in Florida it's just a game
you have to understand that that's
what's going on and now two right-wing
Florida radio hosts plus Phil Valentine
from uh
was it Georgia Tennessee I think
Tennessee
multiple anti-vaxx right-wing radio
hosts have now died of covid let's go on
to the next similar story we now have
also learned not only about a police
officer not only about an anti-vaccine
police officer but an anti-vaccine
police captain who was taking Ivermectin
to combat covid-19 has died of covet 19.
this is being reported by Yahoo news a
Georgia police officer who frequently
posted anti-vaccine messages on Facebook
and took an anti-parasitic drug instead
of a vaccine has died of covid-19
Captain Joe Manning 57 years old
remember we're not talking about 80 year
olds here last guy Mark Bernier was 65.
this police captain was 57 Captain Joe
Manning 57 of the Wayne County Sheriff's
Office died on Wednesday after a short
battle with the virus Sheriff Chuck
Mosley said Captain Manning was an
integral part of our family and our
hearts are broken our love and prayers
go forward to his family would have been
nice to include a get the vaccine keep
your families safe
after the announcement of his death
Facebook posts made by Manning
circulated on social media uh he posted
a couple of different things uh
summarized uh here by Ken klippenstein I
am not vaccinated by choice and that's
my right he posted that
um Joe Manning truth it's not the
government's job to protect my health
it's the government's job to protect my
rights of course everything is
misspelled there's no apostrophes it's
my job to protect my health when you
trade for Liberty when you trade liberty
for safety you end up losing both
um okay folks Wayne Feed and Seed has
some liquid and paste Ivermectin get it
while supplies last he was promoting
Ivermectin and he has now died of covet
19.
um this is I I still see this as a
tragedy I don't see this and go what a
great thing now many of you have been
writing in and saying David this might
actually start to affect elections if
you have Republicans not getting
vaccinated at higher rates than
Democrats that means you're going to
have Republicans dying at higher rates
than Democrats at a certain point this
could lead to Republicans losing some
seats because too many of their voters
are dying you're absolutely right and if
that happens that's going to happen and
it'll be good for Democrats but I still
take no pleasure in the death and
suffering of people there are you know
some of these people tomorrow we're
going to talk about Caleb Wallace the
militia anti-mask militia dude who died
of covid
um as much of a prick as he might be
as much of a doofus as he might be as
much of a terrible person as he might be
he left behind kids and a widow and uh
at least as far as the kids are
concerned
um this is not their fault and now they
are left without a dad because of this
so it's very hard for me to take
pleasure in that but I recognize at a
certain point the numbers could actually
get so lopsided in terms of Republicans
versus Democrats dying that it could
affect some races and in fact the math
of it is that if this continues being
really bad in Florida for another six to
eight months you could actually have a
partisan Gap in Florida bigger in terms
of deaths than Ron desantis's margin of
victory in 2018. I've looked at the
numbers before I'll explain the numbers
again that's not for today let's take a
quick break we'll follow up on the Caleb
Wallace thing tomorrow but much more
upcoming in mere moments
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show there's a
fascinating new chart from The New York
Times and the MIT media lab and this
Compares coveted cases per 100 people
meaning per capita covid to how people
voted in the 2020 presidential election
and the results are so simple that it's
almost surprising but then once you
think about it once you look at it you
realize actually it's not really that
surprising and the bottom line of the
findings are as follows if there are
lots of trump voters there's lots of
covid right now over the last month if
there's a medium amount of trump voters
there's a medium amount of covid over
the last month and if there aren't that
many Trump uh voters there's really not
that much covid spreading either so
let's take a look at the image and very
very nicely put together so what you're
seeing here are five separate lines
which track new cases per 100
000. so the Blue Line means there are
under 20 Trump voters in the county this
is a county by county thing if you're
not watching I'm going to describe this
to you and then it goes from the blue
line all the way up to the bright red
line that means more than 80 percent of
a county has Trump voters now remember
that if you go back to the beginning
before we knew much about covid early
covid hit the places with the big
airports that are directly connected to
Asia and Europe and those are mostly in
blue States so early on at the start of
the pandemic and you look to the left
side of the chart in April you saw that
it was blue counties with more covid
because we had this airport-based
initial spread you had New York City you
had Boston Newark Airport over over the
water in Jersey San Francisco eventually
La Etc
now after a year and a half of the
pandemic having vaccines understanding
guidelines you've essentially seen that
since roughly August or September of
2020 it's been the red counties that on
a per capita basis are leading the covid
case rates the more red the county the
more they are leading in terms of cases
and that's not good the lowest new case
rates right now
are in the counties with fewer than 20
percent of the population less than 20
percent of the population fewer than 20
Trump voters those are the places with
the least covet followed by the places
with 20 to 40 percent Trump
and then the places with 40 to 60
percent Trump voters have more coveted
and then the places with 60 to 80
percent Trump have more coveted and the
places over the last month with the
highest per capita coveted case rates
are the counties where more than 80
percent of the population voted for
Donald Trump and it's not by a small
margin if you look at those 20 or or or
lower percent Trump counties
they only have 25 new cases per hundred
thousand if you look at the 80 plus
percent Trump counties they have 65 new
cases per hundred thousand in other
words the big Trump Counties have about
two and a half just shy of three times
the new case rate then do the very
Democratic leading counties it's truly
incredible to see this translate
perfectly into virus spread now we
expected this intuitively we expected
this but the data shows it cleanly and
clearly now you might correctly say this
can't be good for winning elections
right like in other words if it's mostly
your voters who are getting sick and
overwhelmingly your voters that are
going to the hospital and overwhelmingly
your voters that are dying that probably
isn't good for winning elections right
and you would be completely correct
except Republicans aren't actually
trying to win by having more people who
agree with them go out and vote
Republicans for a long time and recently
and into the future are trying to win by
planning to suppress the vote and making
it harder for people unlikely to vote
for them to actually be able to get a
vote counted uh not by winning people
over on policy ideas that being said
let's go back to the discussion that we
had last week last week we talked about
how Florida's death toll now exceeds Ron
DeSantis margin of victory in 2018. now
it's not relevant yet because that death
toll includes uh includes children who
don't vote
um who weren't part of that margin of
Victory it includes non-voter non-voting
adults as well and it's a mix of
Republicans and Democrats but it is
absolutely plausible that over time the
partisans split in deaths if it
continues to shift to where it goes to
being you know 55 of the deaths are
Republicans sixty percent of the deaths
are Republicans 70 eventually you could
get a partisan Gap such that you have
enough more additional Republicans dying
of covid that it starts to impact
elections now sadly we can't just look
away and say to each their own let them
go and kill themselves because
vaccinated people still can get sick not
everybody can get vaccinated vaccinated
people could end up in the hospital
vaccinated people could end up dying in
part thanks to the increased spread
caused by the right wing anti-vaccine
people but it's a very similar pattern
to what we saw with the Spanish Flu
early earlier urban areas got hit harder
we saw that with covet as well
more because of airports it's unclear
about the effect of the population
density but there may be one but by the
end of the day by now what we are seeing
is that it's the most conservative areas
the most Trump voting areas many of
which are rural that are getting hit the
hardest and it's two things it's the
lower rate of vaccination and it's a
higher rate of ignoring all of the
guidelines that at this point we have a
pretty good understanding of in terms of
preventing covid so an unsurprising
chart but very informative in terms of
it can feel vague I don't know we can't
see the virus I'm just with friends this
can't be a bad thing or I didn't get a
shot but again it translates to real
world data and we see it very clearly
there not a factor here uh our religious
beliefs but the Republican governor of
Mississippi Tate Reeves certainly seems
to think that that is a factor and I
want to talk about that a little bit
next
Mississippi's Governor Tate Reeves
says that there's a reason that in
Mississippi people are just kind of
going about their business normally
maybe not getting vaccinated as much Etc
and the reason is that because in
Mississippi more people are religious
meaning they believe in an afterlife
they believe in eternal life they
believe in heaven they are less scared
of the virus this is Governor Tate
Reeves
um let's look at the article from
Business Insider Mississippi Governor
Tate Reeves and remarks Saturday said
that people in the state were less
scared of covid because they believe in
eternal life as new infections reach
record levels and hospitalization Spike
now remember Mississippi is highly
infected
and under-resourced when you look at
Health Care quality and access
Mississippi is usually 50th out of 50
states sometimes 49th they're engaged in
a battle for the to the race to the
bottom with Alabama when it comes to
health care okay it's a disaster in
Mississippi and the governor is saying
well we believe in an eternal life so
we're not that scared Reeves made the
remarks to a gathering of State
Republicans at a fundraiser on Thursday
quote I'm often asked by some of my
friends on the other side of the aisle
about covid and why does it seem like
folks in Mississippi and maybe in the
Mid-South are a little less scared shall
we say when you believe in eternal life
when you believe that living on this
Earth is but a blip on the screen then
you don't have to be so scared of things
Reeves went on to say God also tells us
to take necessary precautions and we all
have opportunities and abilities to do
that and we should all do that I
encourage everyone to do so Mississippi
has recorded more new coveted cases per
capita than any state around 127 per 100
000 according to an analysis by the New
York Times the wave of infections in
Mississippi has put State Health
Services at a Breaking Point with 93
percent of ICU beds in use 63 percent of
those occupied by covid patients
according to HHS data now you know the
thing about these kind of claims we're
less scared because this uh Earthly life
is an is only a blip in terms of the
total life this would sort of apply to
everything like seat belts taking
antibiotics when you have a sinus
infection or strep throat and yet most
of these people do these things there
are some like I know Christian Science
is very much uh skeptical of medication
and sort of traditional treatment uh Etc
but this applies to a lot of different
things that most of them do but if
you're really going to take this
approach you should really take it fully
don't take the mealy-mouthed approach
don't go to the hospital when you get
sick right go to church and pray or even
don't do anything because you're going
to more quickly get to that Eternal
afterlife if you die from whatever is
afflicting you there's also another more
sensible approach which I think I've
seen seen some religious left-wingers
take which is God made the vaccine
possible I'm gonna go and get the
freaking vaccine right when God answers
prayers God may be answering the prayers
by giving us a vaccine or giving us
masks or giving us ways to attend church
safely in our cars or whatever the case
may be it it almost starts to take on
like if you really take this to its full
conclusion it starts to take on kind of
this Rapture porn ideology of the sooner
I die the sooner I get to heaven and
some of these Rapture belief systems
take that on they say it's going to be
so great it's gonna I hope that the
Rapture comes and we all are uh you know
that there's fire and fury and whatever
else they believe Brimstone what are the
terms they use I don't remember because
I'm going to get to heaven sooner
um and I read a tweet from a religious
person who said I believe in eternal
life that's my religious belief but I
believe in taking precautions to avoid
covid because I'm in no rush to exit
this life I don't know if in the
afterlife I can be with my kids I just
don't know what that's going to be like
I believe in it but I don't know what
it's going to be so you know what I'm
going to get the vaccine and I'm going
to try to stay safe it's a completely
delusional perspective from Tate Reeves
but it's also being applied
hypocritically uh because a lot of these
people they wear seat belts and they
take antibiotics and they wear a helmet
when they ride their motorcycle whatever
the case may be but yet on this one
they're saying there's no reason to be
scared of this because we believe in an
afterlife it's really scary stuff and
unfortunately it is not an uncommon set
of beliefs in the United States we have
a voicemail number and that number is
2192 David P
I have to tell you I don't really
understand this caller I'm going to play
this for you maybe we can figure it out
together
I don't know what's up with the audio by
the way I I'm aware of it
Sparks
and mask wearing
I just really blew me away and left me
wondering what you spend your spare time
researching
I can only hope
that in the future you don't have a clip
where somebody claims that mass cannot
prevent
homosexual intercourse
come on David
later anybody have any idea what that's
about like I don't even know what
segment it relates to because
we talk about masks and I I don't know
it's a very very strange voicemail if
anybody has even the slightest inkling
what that might be about please let me
know on today's bonus show we will be
talking about hurricane Ida which hit
the Gulf Coast as a category 4 storm
cash shortages at ATMs gas shortages you
can't get cash to buy gas that isn't
there anyway to get out people in dire
dire circumstances
um in Louisiana and elsewhere we will
discuss that reports of cheating at
colleges have exploded during the
Pandemic part of it is sort of intuitive
if there's a lot of work from home and
test from home stuff happening it's
easier to cheat but is there something
else to it uh psychologically going on
making people more willing to cheat
during covet we will talk about that on
today's bonus show and then lastly many
of you requesting this story
and when the people ask for it I will
oblige
um disgraced right-wing darling Milo
yiannopoulos not only has covid but
apparently has been injecting himself
with
um a dosage of ivermectin met for
livestock and even looking at the
picture of the syringe that Milo posted
it looks like a pretty wide gauge
syringe that it it doesn't look like
that thin coveted vaccine syringe I
don't know how many needle rather I
don't know how many of you have seen I
know many of you have you've gotten
vaccinated if you didn't look away when
you were getting the covet vaccine the
needle is incredibly thin it's a notably
it's it's almost a perfect needle I
would say
um the the needle that uh Milo posted is
quite a thick gauge and I don't know
what the hell is going on but we're
going to talk about the latest with Milo
and ivermect and his covid and just
whether he's trying to use this to mount
another comeback I actually recently
engaged I had a very very brief email
back and forth with Milo a few months
ago before he uh got covered I will talk
a little bit about that and then we will
also talk about the what we believe is
the resolution to last week's Tech
issues I have some updates on that I got
some very important suggestions from
people in the audience so that's all
today on the bonus show I want to remind
you we may be as little as 24 hours
from reaching 1 billion YouTube views on
our YouTube on our main YouTube channel
one billion YouTube views uh it is an
incredible milestone in a sense it's
more impressive than a million
subscribers and I will talk about why
once we reach the Milestone we have a
beautiful video planned that producer
Pat put together for us along with help
from Noah and and it's it's a great
video we've got ready it's it's queued
up and ready to go when we get to that
billion and we will also have a
fantastic membership special go out to
our newsletter subscribers when we get
to that billion views so make sure
you're signed up at davidpackman.com but
before any of that today's bonus show
join me there I will see you then
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com David Pacman